[Laughter]
smoking [ __ ] death today understand
me [ __ ]
greetings concept of Thursday the 15th
of December coming to you from the
Garden of Good and Evil it's cloudy it's
gonna rain but who gives a [ __ ] I still
got a job to do I don't feel good I'm
depressed the hallways the holidays get
me down well go suck it they can get
your life together ok depression is for
[ __ ] [ __ ] we're men here ok you
grab your balls
you shall loot the [ __ ] flag and you
say you know what whatever happens today
happens but I'm the captain of this
[ __ ] enterprise you understand
me we're here with weird [ __ ]
smoking the best from perennials now
cookies I'm gonna go pick up the [ __ ]
badge at 10 a.m. for the weekend the one
I drew called my man from Russia called
I got weed for the [ __ ] holidays it's
gonna kill Santa you understand that's a
weed that killed [ __ ] Santa there's
no [ __ ] cookies and milk in my house
there's a big [ __ ] joint on the
[ __ ] table let me tell you something
by the time he gets down in the corner I
[ __ ] gonna be all [ __ ] up but
your podcasts to bulk up from bas Rutten
to my girl whatever my [ __ ] name is
that badass [ __ ] that put ecstasy up
her [ __ ]
that's tremendous I've never put
anything up my [ __ ] but now that I'm
clean and sober I wish I would have put
a coke rock up my ass or I'll really
seen Colombia from the inside you know
I'm saying but besides that that's it
you got 9 shoplifting days 10
shoplifting days what are you not doing
your [ __ ] life you're gonna sit down
what am I gonna do it's over tomorrow
it's over the city closes it down
everybody's got presents and here comes
Santa Claus here come not me I'm a Cuban
Jew [ __ ] I work till the [ __ ]
last man drops
that's it and that's that machine I'm
saying you had to go you're not feeling
well for your feet hurt I had a rough
day yesterday well what's so rough did
you get raped he's getting ahead with a
bunch of black [ __ ] no your boss told
you you're a [ __ ] loser that's right
so strapped around a [ __ ] seat belt
and stop being a [ __ ] loser how you
smoke a bong you're right your goals and
you stick to it I don't give a [ __ ] if
it gets fundamental and boring you stick
to it
I'm a fat [ __ ] mouth at jujitsu but I
go three times a week I get beat up
every [ __ ] time but you know what it
don't matter I keep showing the [ __ ]
up that's the word of the day keep
showing up yeah like sucking that keep
showing up yeah like eat ass keep
showing up you want to be smart keep
reading the [ __ ] book what do I know
you don't saying you took it to a
[ __ ] [ __ ] here what so now another
dismal I'm got to [ __ ] put it
together I don't know how I did it but
you know what I didn't give up don't
give up get all these [ __ ] losers out
of your life
surround yourself with two or three
[ __ ] killers they each got one good
thing to offer you and you [ __ ] take
it and you add it on to your [ __ ]
reputable genius I just hung out with
[ __ ] killers and each of them had one
good thing to offer and I took that day
and here we are [ __ ] 53 years later
slinging dick
I got a few felonies but [ __ ] you
can't make an omelet unless you break
some [ __ ] eggs you don't saying
I shall get the press for Christmas you
know what
come on time to bleep you're gonna have
a bad Christmas you're not gonna have
money things are bad eh and happens
terribly one for another you understand
me just get ready for 2017 because
you're coming out the [ __ ] box like
Moses out of the beach you know I'm
saying I just split the [ __ ] beach
what else you want from me
get the suck in [ __ ] I didn't bring
no Ten Commandments I brought one
commandment sniff my [ __ ] nut sack
you follow me anyway that's it I got
nothing else to tell you like I said
you're two podcasts up and I'm just
saying getting stung like a [ __ ]
with my favorite beeping I got a 12
o'clock audition I got to clap I'm doing
the hot ones I'm gonna go eat some
chicken wings I'm bringing my blue
cheese like a [ __ ]
I got [ __ ] a little back exercises I
gotta go to a five and then I got a spot
at the commies foot 10:45 what are you
gonna do with your [ __ ] life -
hey I'll pick my daughter I gotta feed
it you know the [ __ ] whole thing here
but it doesn't matter it's life you were
just I don't even then he's crying no
more this is the church that I haven't
mentality or the church like a Jew you
understand you don't give a [ __ ] you
cutting off people and smiling at these
[ __ ] but Joey which would be a
beatin coming where's that [ __ ]
reform spark on it comes everything I
mean I care so much it's a hybrid the
indica is like a [ __ ] the this a team
is like a blaster [ __ ] coke kind of
[ __ ] Saturday night
[Music]
look at that what the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with some novice what do
you think should we do one more I mean
what the [ __ ] it's Thursday correct only
under you can't walk on one leg then you
gotta say uncle Joey made me go on
Barry's go even get high [ __ ] you I've
been smoking this Rufus in six twenty
this morning for twenty could suck my
dick I got up at ten to six brush my
teeth took a nice long pitch drank some
[ __ ] coffee wrote my [ __ ] epilogue
for the day what I'm gonna do and how I
feel and then I hit that [ __ ] pipe at
61 even the [ __ ] skunks were running
when they saw him with Joey one more for
the road
it is my best part of the day with you
guys and I know you look at me Tom he's
a [ __ ] loser he's an idiot
maybe I am I am I am buddy but for me
get my will you [ __ ] this
brightens my day I get out what I gotta
say
you guys get to see your uncle Joey
because that's the most important thing
if you don't see your uncle Joey
everything out of this
you got that uncle he hangs out at the
[ __ ] store you don't see him for a
few days you got a little [ __ ] sad
I'm here [ __ ] so I always be here
for you [ __ ] you guys know that
because what are you what do I got not
much I got my friend you don't see the
[ __ ] hanging around me I'm a
solo like this but I love you
[ __ ] and that's all that
matters from the bottom from the bottom
of my fat little [ __ ] heart and you
know what's crazy you love [ __ ] know
it you know I don't [ __ ] around when it
comes to you office that's it and that's
that we smoke dope we crack a few jokes
we learn a few things
and you go home and then you execute
when you're [ __ ] her you know I love
you
[Music]
I love you [ __ ] all right have
a phenomenal day only nobody [ __ ] with
you and it's your world these
[ __ ] are visiting all right if
you don't eat broccoli don't eat it
don't do it just because nothing
well my [ __ ] [ __ ] friends did [ __ ]
them [ __ ] them and get rid of them you
gotta get good people on your [ __ ]
solid [ __ ] savages don't give a [ __ ]
if you stabbed my mother suck at 3:00 in
the morning and you koala me
they say [ __ ] I'm going down in a
bell yard I'm gonna stab him again those
are the [ __ ] people you want you know
I have those people they're just [ __ ]
acquaintances yeah I'm saying I love you
stay black or you didn't come out might
get our bingo a solid come on bingo
nothing come on my life particularly
well your bingo walk it won't have me
metro beating the higher I love you
[ __ ]